Thank You economist my last audio book
win world war 2011 probably recording
from December 2010 know how to write
sadhana from social media I do things I
look at things from this lens that know
something fun cool and I find it
interesting and I want to share I share
I'm usually of the nature of being more
private than than anything but some
people who and as opportu talking you
I've always been told people just want
to see just the dumbest is that you do
try to you may not find it interesting
but everybody else finds it you just
because it's a lens into your world and
whatnot so getting a little bit more
comfortable with that right so you know
just so I keep aligning things I'll get
more detailed about this in 16 I don't I
don't believe in anything
thank you so much
look at this kitchen
sir when he starts a daily reaction to
edit yeah because I have a lot I mean I
never anything my own stuff better
before right but I have to watch this
there's so much right I know I mean I
excuses now it was like that pops lately
i watch that was like to be like because
for me it was easy I was going up
against something where I would mark it
and then I would see it come through the
dot-com shopping cart before my register
in the store right so I never had to
debate the things that you have to
debate the big shock to me when I came
into corporate America yeah 49 Brown
it uses Graham last yeah even the stuff
that's been beneficial Tortoises data
logics yeah you know for me when I do
business meetings it's kind of
interesting i I just so know where my
intent and my skills are that I actually
not judge but I sized up the other side
based on how they react to me because if
it goes well it means they're seeing
what I'm saying there's a belief on
there's an alignment on the religion
you've got to back it up now and then
you put but I want to put myself on the
hook and I'm always so thankful when
very senior people are not posturing to
the history they're they're open-minded
they're bringing their strong points of
view as well but it's like a it's a fair
debate it's honest it's lacks emotion
it's just business and um it's just a
great way to get the day going to have
to have an invigorating high-level input
meeting that was fair and by the way if
I don't get any business or my business
doesn't grow and I felt that was fair
and that's happened in the past cuz I
don't think what I do or what we do
aligns with them I also feel good it's
not about the win it's about the
fairness meritocracy baby even at your
own expense something a lot of people
haven't yet
that's fine 0:04 or maybe I can see her
over the weekend if she wants to stop by
and see the kids because she's family
friend with Dave so ask okay okay
i hi there Harry Rick Rick against nice
thing is I'm excited is that the
questions are already read yes so it's
gonna be interesting to see we'll put
you on headphones it's gonna hear the
question if you look play the questions
huge and you know what's crazy I have a
crazy idea do what's interesting you
want to talk about you want to talk
about why the audiobook huh
okay cool I'm excited I think the school
is gonna go really well will be great
yeah what's better than uh you know it's
actually really rad how do I answer in
the book how do I answer in the
audiobook like what little subtle things
changed in a three or four month period
mean if I could just send just answer
questions done more seconds come on air
cozy you studios in New York City that
has a window in there with a little of
it human buying rice which is a large
book take a second catch up in my life
case I'm getting the iPad
here's your audiobook Thank You economy
Thank You economist my last audiobook
when mobile 2011 they came out March
11th so I probably recording it in
December 2010 that's one thing that
chooses five years ago when I got more
paper I don't know if you're gonna need
this you may not want it but that's a
list of the questions of who's asking
the order would take them up a simple
whether you want this page like that
it's like literally everything some page
yeah I'm going on not awful guy may be
really good open press but Harper Gary
b1 oh yeah a little later there's a
Missy Elliott lyric okay you can't sing
I'm that's not an evaluation of that
people are actually reading questions
and I'm answering and
all right so we're anticipating some
improvisation here yes but let's try
reading obviously want to read it under
bandits yeah there's the opening setups
that's what I learned and then when I
was reading it myself it was funny how I
was there was something interesting
going on which is I wanted like I
improved eight two four eight to
thirteen percent my first two bucks here
I could see going a little a lot more
because this is now from a business
standpoint there is an absolute scenario
here where a lot of people could end up
buying both the book and the audio box
yes if I make them aware that I
basically use a difference what this
more value is different are they some of
these answers I gave a year and I mean
by the way some of them I'm gonna I saw
how to write like things changed even
when I can change them anymore and it
all very good we've got a lot of
material to do got a lot to do there's
only one cardinal rule but I listened to
the audio that I that was up on audible
for the last book yeah thank you pace
was great water rushing the big
temptation is to push too fast
yeah I think ho-bag I feel very good
about the time that we've allocated I
think in general you'll see that I'll
probably start a little bit too hard
because I'm excited course um but cool
yeah can you hear me perfect
your wonderful moments alright so what I
was forgetting levels and things of that
sort to the veiniacs it's the first and
dedication if you will for we do know
yeah just because I better that's not
going to give us an upside down a
terrace so let me get you read back and
go level go to the veiniacs and the
vaynernation and all the people who have
watched even one video over the last ten
years your attention is my oxygen Harper
audio presents askgaryvee one
entrepreneurs take on leadership social
media and self awareness by gary
vay-ner-chuk
do I say the word acknowledgement yeah
acknowledgments nothing I do is possible
without the support of my family my
heart belongs to my wife Lizzie and my
kids Misha and Xander at the time I
really did think I was done with daily
video blogging forever
I could imagine the occasional interview
or one-off video have you seen my Monday
morning motivational spot but a full
show was too much there was only one
thing I didn't count on you the
vaynernation I missed you
meanwhile the emails kept pouring in
despite access to three books and
hundreds of videos people still had
questions how to successfully use social
media the new platforms and the old
standbys to build the brands or how to
market with native content or even just
how do I do what I do there was so much
content I wouldn't there was so much
content I wanted to put out to help them
but with all my other obligations at
vaynermedia and elsewhere I just
couldn't get to it and that's how on
July 31st 2014 on a YouTube channel with
30,000 subscribers one of the world's
first business Q&A video blogs was
launched it opened with a guy in a blue
striped golf shirt smiling into the
camera hello everybody and oh
my adventure hello everyone and welcome
to the first ask gary vee though the
first episode started off almost as
low-key as its wine themed predecessors
by the second the light and the sound
quality were professional-grade and the
host was bringing hard energy and
straight thunder at first i thought the
show might be an every now and then
thing but it was like riding a bike as
soon as i film the first episode i want
to do more and just as i could never run
out of new wines to taste there will
never be a day where there's nothing new
to say about the state of business its
consistently evolving and grits it'sa
constantly it's a constantly evolving
and growing topic one more it's a
constantly it's a constantly evolving
and growing topic good met by the way
you're doing a great job thank you
helping me a lot
give you one second even though i wanted
to get through that five just a second
okay we're about ten fifteen percent
behind understood a little bit beyond
yep although i think we've found them
i'm sorry to break it up it up I'll be
up days fast as I can
is there a bathroom out here yes there
is
looking looking to jumpstart the
conversation in a more healthy Jewish
chapter 1 plows enter I'm a really
really good idea
I'm listening and then I'm gonna really
take your advice on this I'm gonna read
this answer and then I'm gonna listen to
it and I'm gonna answer it I have a
feeling that we're gonna get a much
better audio book and and go much faster
but not faster like speed just like it's
gonna come much Matt more natural to
with the second way of doing it okay
yeah so I think that's going to work and
I think it's gonna work consistently the
shorter the answer if you've got a four
paragraph answer it's really harder for
you to sort of recap it all as live I'm
guessing it could be this thing let's
yeah let's find out let's find out how
long is too long for a fiscally
responsible entrepreneur to stay in a
safe full-time job at what point do you
have to accept that it's not going to
happen is it ever too late to start this
question on the show created a firestorm
after I answered what I still believe
today so with all due respect to all
your collective feedback I'm gonna go
there again if you work in a job you are
not an entrepreneur now I know that
hurts and I'm going to say it again if
you right now is your as you're running
through the airport or driving on the
highway are going to a job you my friend
are not an entrepreneur you may have
entrepreneurial tendencies but you are
not entrepreneur now let me take a step
back deploy a little humility in the
bravado that I'm about to spit being an
entrepreneur a purebred entrepreneur the
way that I see it this is one man's
point of view this is the askgaryvee
book after all is somebody who doesn't
even have the ability to have ever had a
job the reason I was an F student and
I'd like to think most of you realize at
this point I'm no dope I'm not a dummy
it was because I couldn't deploy going
through that machine which was built to
go get a job and I wasn't honing the
skills that I knew I had to have to be
who I was and I knew this at nine years
old at 12 years old at 15 years old at
my junior year of high school I'm
sitting in science class reading The
Wine Spectator I'm doing that because
I'm prepping to be a wine merchant
because I was an entrepreneur there was
nothing else if my dad didn't have a
liquor store I would have built on the
fact that I was making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards and the malls of
New Jersey as a 15 year old you don't
think I could have lived on thirty six
thousand a year for working 52 days a
year I sure could have and so that's who
I was there was nothing else now a lot
of you said this is unfair of me this
that the other thing what I want you to
know is my definition of an entrepreneur
should not be yours you want to think
you're not tripping or because you do
what I said and crush it and come home
from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
and build a business you want to tell me
about the fact that you have student
loans and you have to pay them off and
that's why you have to do it I get it
but I would flip it on you I think an
entrepreneur works on their
entrepreneurship and then works at
7-eleven from 11:00 p.m. at night to
6:00 in the morning on the graveyard
shift if they have to be practical
because you have to understand and you
have to understand there is nothing else
it's like telling a singer that they
can't sing they have to sing at night
there is nothing else you're drawn to it
you can't breathe it is your absolute
oxygen you are an entrepreneur when you
are building your business at all times
and let me say another thing this is not
1992 anymore it is actually way more
practical to be an entrepreneur than
it's ever been before if you're 22 years
old if you were not willing to sleep on
the floor with nine of your buddies in a
studio apartment then you are not an
entrepreneur if you want to get a job
because you want to watch or you want a
car or you want to be able to take out
girls for a nice dinner that you are not
an entrepreneur that entrepreneur does
entrepreneur things and that is by
definition building a business for
yourself period end of story
well cool the notes help me quite a bit
on that one but I'm taking the notes a
little more seriously I think is going
to be really impactful every system is
this what is it like
if you want to say skill because I've
been honing them for 32 of my 40 years
then you can say skill that's kind of
cool that was cool that was a good one
okay
logs to a five man this this nope thing
is crushing about 10 more minutes first
15 questions that come in be a snapchat
right now I will answer just had dinner
with my folks and Lizzy Anisha now about
to start another meeting got to go back
across the street a little bit reading
maybe tired